[موسيقى]
ربما كان هذا هو الوقت الأكثر رعبًا في
حياتي، كان من المفترض أن يكون من
أسعد الأوقات التي كانت فيها كلوديا دوفال حامل
للمرة الأولى لكنها تقول إن المخاوف
والأفكار المتطفلة أبقتها على حافة الهاوية ولم
تسوء إلا بعد
ولادة ابنتها  بدأت بالقلق المفرط،
ونوبات عميقة من الاكتئاب، كانت شديدة
اليقظة، كنت أنظف
بقلق شديد مجرد سلوكيات، وأنا
آسف لأنني أدركت أننا لسنا طبيعيين،
وأرشدتها إحالة OB GYN إلى منظمة غير ربحية
تسمى دعم ما بعد الولادة
الدولي للرعاية العقلية في الفترة المحيطة بالولادة
تعد الاضطرابات الصحية أكثر شيوعًا مما
يدركه الناس،
ويقول المدير التنفيذي للمنظمة إن العديد من النساء
إما لا يعرفن أن لديهن الأعراض
ولا يدركن أن الأعراض قد تكون
مؤقتة وقابلة للعلاج أو يشعرن بالحرج الشديد
من الحصول على المساعدة التي
ساعد نظام الدعم في تطويرها.  لقد نجحت
في حملها الثاني حتى عندما
شعرت بنفس المخاوف، لقد أعددت
نفسي حقًا لأي شيء تعرفه
يمكن أن يأتي في طريقي إلى دوفال، حيث
أحدثت هذه المعرفة فرقًا كبيرًا في
الصحة، أنا آندي غايثر